my new year's resolution for to the 15
is to break down the global structures
of empire and finish my netflix queue
whichever comes first my new year's
resolution is to read more fiction
starting with at the playground
my new year's resolution for 2015 is to
be the voice of one animated character
in a movie some always a farm animal I
don't make resolutions my new year's
resolution is to watch more than me my
new year's resolution is to save my
garden that has been destroyed by a
Santeria curse I think my new year's
resolution for 2015 would be to put on
20 kilos my resolution is to try to
meditate and live in the present more
it's hard
you